baby get up get up well it does this to
me all the time Veronica's here mucci
all right good a committee across won't
meet her are you crazy you're naked walk
address not a problem gonna dress me oh
we doing it all you have breakfast
together get to know each other what we
want to leave me it's just a great way
hey misty I need a background check seat
24e Tom Bowen V owel unlawfully subdued
innocent passengers marks don't assume
you've lost your supervisor before the
flight in threatened else you wouldn't
look it over time fighting you said you
do what you have that didn't threaten
anything is that right oh I need to run
a full check on Tom Bowen seat 24e are
now you're wasting tart agent marks you
are hereby relieved of duty do you hear
me three minutes someone on this plane
is gonna die do you hear me
Oh
the hits just keep on coming with you
huh never does you go by her gucci and
as the god-king stood before his people
Artemisia watched her flawless
manipulation takes shape for glory sick
of NGC
variants as you wish your highness who's
that mr. Peabody King Tut my boyfriend
King Tut is her boyfriend who would you
like me to have them skinned covered
with honey and lay it in a pit of fire
red do you do that for me anything my
desert flower consider it a wedding gift
what get married his guy why not well
for one his name rhymes with but i don't
care i'm gonna have a big fat Egyptian
wedding spoiler alert Kinta dies young
are you sure you've thought this through
Oh trust me I thought it